[Music]
oh okay hey everyone how's it going I
hope you are well so I thought to myself
the other day it's been a while since I
did a question and answer video I think
about a year um and I wanted to do one
so welcome to my living room that is all
cozy and decked out for fall because
fall is my favorite season got my cup of
coffee right here and I guess we can get
started before we do start though I
wanted to talk about two projects that
I've been working on that I'm really
excited about and I want you all to know
about and love just as much as I do
because I've been really excited about
it so the first one is a web series
called crash course put on by Microsoft
um it's a four-part series with
five-minute videos where we explain
complex software engineering ideas
concepts and trends using like these
little toys that are all within the room
I am the host of the show so I'm in all
four episodes it's really fun we talk
about things like get ops and dev
workflows as well as bots frameworks and
servos architecture a lot of these
things I didn't know that much about
until I went on set and I learned about
it so I really hope you check it out it
was so much fun filming in two days for
Seattle with an entire crew one of my
favorite memories of the last
20-something years that I've been alive
so I really hope you like it link is in
the description please check it out is
so much fun and I'm a host of a show
it's like I'm on TV the second one is a
more recent thing I have a podcast the
podcast is called if/else and we teach
you and talk about how to make decisions
in a technical career so career
decisions technical decisions the whole
gamut I am really excited about it so
please check it out in the description
box down below the first episode comes
out today I think so
yeah go check it out cool so now for the
Q&A portion of the video so I went on
social media as I do
person in 2019 and asked questions on
Instagram and Twitter just general
questions is about life and tech and
coding and me and whatever and a lot of
you wrote in so thank you so much to
everyone who wrote in and really
appreciate your questions so the first
question comes from Instagram and it
reads what age did you start programming
and especially how did you know that it
was what you wanted to do in the future
so I started programming I'll be the
first time that I wrote a line of code
was in high school and not because I
wanted to learn programming but because
I wanted to I think like to change my
Zynga theme or something like that thing
it was a blog that existed in the early
2000s so that was probably the first
time that I ever looked at code the
first time that I was kind of like oh
this is kind of what I want to do now
was when I was 18 in college so I hadn't
done any coding before that and how did
I know that this is what I wanted to do
for the rest of my life I didn't and I
still don't know to be completely honest
with you at the time it was just like it
just made sense to me um I really like
logical problem-solving and I liked the
sciences and I wanted to go into a space
where like job security was a thing
because I needed to be financially
independent so that was kind of the
whole reason and I'm always thinking
like is this what I'm gonna be doing for
the next 30 to 50 years
I don't know I really don't have the
answer but I think figuring out what's
right in front of you and doing that is
an important skill in mentality to have
I actually have a whole video about how
I got into software engineering so leave
it in the card right here or maybe it's
over here
I don't know I'll just go like this next
time I told you there is gonna be a lot
of links it's a lot of links today but
doing a lot of stuff but not necessarily
on my channel and I want you all to know
all the cool stuff that I've been doing
because it's been so cool
so the next question and the next couple
of questions are related to what is life
like in Silicon Valley so first question
how expensive is it to live in the
valley and what do SWE's waste so much
money on that's a good question huh I
don't know I think it depends on the
person I don't think
waste their money hopefully um but yeah
how do I explain how expensive is it to
live in the valley I would say like rent
is one indicator I think most people in
the valley are spending anywhere between
1500 to upwards of eight thousand
dollars per month on rent and this
depends on the city that you live in and
the type of house that you live in as
well as roommates most of my friends
have roommates and so typically they'll
pay between 1500 and 2500 in that range
but if you're gonna get a place for
yourself then yeah it's definitely gonna
cost at least I would say like four
thousand dollars even for like a
one-bedroom in some city so that's
expensive most houses in the Bay Area
are $1,000,000 and more even like
two-bedroom two-bath like 1,500 square
feet places are about that much a cup of
coffee costs about five dollars I mean
yeah it's expensive I think it's kind of
a chicken and the egg problem because
software engineers and tech people get
paid a lot but also because things are
expensive things are expensive because
software engineer and tech people get
paid a lot I don't know what people
spend their money on I think a lot of
people in the Bay Area save up to buy
property and a house but there's also
arguments that renting is gonna be
cheaper here too because houses are so
expensive yeah it's expensive I would
say it's very expensive to live here so
the next question is kind of related is
a high standard of living in the Bay
Area worth it um I guess it depends on
what you want out of living here I think
that coming here to build your network
and to build your skills and work at
lots of companies like it's absolutely
worth it there's a wealth of jobs and
people like there's just so many people
working here in text that it is a really
great place to kind of build that and
build relationships but it is really
expensive to live here and I mean
personally I really like living in a
place where there's lots of different
kinds of people that can live there like
because of the high standard of living
in the Bay Area if you don't work in
tech you're gonna have a hard time and a
lot of those people
you've the Bay Area in California
entirely and that really sucks so yeah I
mean career-wise it's totally worth it
pre tech San Francisco and the Bay Area
was and is still a beautiful place to
live there's lots of different kinds of
people here it's very diverse it's
really big there's great nature so it is
a really good place to live
but really depends on what you're
looking for another related question
ever thought of relocating out of the
Bay Area or freelance coding I have
certainly thought about relocating out
of the Bay Area I've thought about
moving home to San Diego I've thought
about finding a new city entirely I
don't know
I mean career-wise it just makes sense
to stay here but I would like to figure
out a way to be a little bit more
location flexible because the Bay Area
because I think the I mean economic
situation is really stressful sometimes
to live in and as far as freelance
coding goes I would love to try it out
I've never done freelance coding your
contracts before I'm and I would really
like to see how that goes so that's
something that I definitely still want
to explore in my career but anybody has
resources or you do it yourself let me
know in the comments down below any
advice or resources or videos or
something that you think would be really
helpful okay quick coffee break nothing
like a good cup of coffee next questions
from Twitter do you ever feel like you
don't want to work as an iOS developer
anymore and try out something else yeah
I have that like I think about that
weekly I think about what would I do if
I wasn't an iOS developer I recently
came to the realization i OS development
is very niche and not everyone needs a
nap so I've been thinking about that a
lot I've also been thinking about if I
wasn't a software developer what would I
be doing I think YouTube is really fun
and I would love to explore that a
little further because it's way more
creative than software engineering and
I'm making videos for me and myself and
what I think is important versus what a
company and other people think are
important so the flexibility
and freedom I guess that that gives is
really cool and awesome and you get to
meet really cool people in the process
but yeah I mean I think about it all the
time and I I don't know if it's just
that the circumstances haven't arisen or
I haven't figured out the right reasons
or there haven't been enough reasons to
actually make a change but I feel like
in the next five years something will
change
so we'll see now for something
completely different
when did you start getting into the
guitar and singing I started playing
guitar in middle school I want to say my
dad bought a classical guitar for
himself and then I started learning
chords on it
singing I've been doing all my life but
I've been taking it way more seriously
recently because it recently started
singing classes sometimes I post videos
of myself singing on Instagram so go
check that out
every once in a while it'll be there I
really like it it's just such a
different way of expressing yourself and
music gives me a lot of energy listening
to it being in music just making it so
it's a very important part of my life
and I'm trying to make it more of a
bigger thing I really like this question
because I've definitely felt this way
before it reads I feel burned out from
drowning in a highly meta opinionated
and pseudo-intellectual atmosphere of
conversations in tech it feels soulless
often what are your thoughts on this oh
man this is a very familiar feeling to
me because I think I think about this a
lot especially like when I was in my
early career I was kind of like how do I
fit into this industry when everyone has
an opinion about everything honestly
it's kind of my biggest like gripe about
the industry and the thing that I shall
go with the most when I feel this way I
have to remember that tech at the end of
the day does sometimes just feel like
websites and code and apps and stuff and
just like the product that gets made but
really it's about all of the people who
pour in so much of their thought and
love into products and the people who
get to consume it and use it to
hopefully make their life better
I try to kind of see the nuance in it
all and that everyone's just trying
their best everyone's trying
get from one place to another I also
think the feeling of like the tech
industry feels really meta and there's
lots of opinions and stuff like yeah the
way that we talk about tech is so that
and I'm not a fan of it to be honest if
you've noticed I don't really like
answer questions and like up this is
what you have to do to be a software
engineer or this is the right and only
way to do stuff because I don't want to
prescribe that to anybody everyone has
different paths in tech there's no one
right way I think there are lots of ways
to get into it that I can help guide you
and show you but there's no right or
wrong way it's a B in tech or to live or
to have an opinion about so I don't
think that it's productive or helpful to
shame anybody or to perpetuate or to
hype something up for that reason I
think it's okay to be excited about tech
I think it's okay to share that
excitement with others and talk about
what you've been looking into but I I
think it's it's real that the impact
that has on some people is that it feels
empty and weird and not the right thing
so I guess what I'm trying to say is if
you ever find yourself in this situation
find other people who feel that same way
about tech and then just have a
conversation about it either about the
fact that the tech industry feel this
way or sometimes I'll just like talk
about feelings with somebody who also
works in tech but then it makes me
realize like oh there are people here
who like really care and who are really
human just in the same way that I am
that makes it feel a little less scary
and empty that is me on my soapbox I
guess yeah it's a hard question I think
it does feel soulless and sometimes I'm
like why why do all these companies
exist but like there's a lot of things
that I don't know about the industry and
there's a lot of problems that people
face that I don't know about either
and I think acknowledging that you don't
know helps kind of free yourself from
that stress and from that pressure
almost to know like you don't have to
know everything you do you like you only
know so much and there's only so much
time in your life and in your day to do
it and if you are making sure that
you're spending your energy
the right places and the right ways that
feel right to you like that's all that
matters and then finding other people
who align with you in that same way I
think really really helps so the next
question is around career changes and
boot camps and so I'm gonna call into
people who are very close to me who have
experience in this welcome to the set
for those of you who don't know this is
Scott this is my husband he's also a
software engineer and this is Ray this
is my little brother you just graduated
from boot camp yeah I just graduated
from UX design boot camp yeah so these
two have real experience doing kind of a
career change and thinking about boot
camps and stuff so I have some questions
for you to answer the first one more for
you Scott yeah I'm a quarter of the way
through my coding boot camp and I was
wondering if coding in the industry is
as intense as boot camps oh I think that
depends that depends on you know project
life cycles where you are if you're an
early stage startup and you're trying to
build out the Minimum Viable Product and
really pushing it before you go broke
next week yeah it's probably very
intense but then if you're at a larger
company with longer schedules for
projects it could just be really relaxed
and you know exploratory and you can
have a very different experience
depending on where you are what's your
experience cuz you work at a start-up
right now that's pretty small it comes
in waves for me definitely depends on
where the product is since we're very
closely knit with what we're doing at
the moment in terms of overall product
strategy sense cool next question is for
you right cool which is I think this
person is considering a role in tech but
they're not sure okay they right for
someone who's fresh out of school and is
contemplating a career in tech but isn't
sure how should they make that decision
which is you because you just graduated
yes yeah
go into coding bootcamp yeah so I think
the most important thing is research
research research I think it's important
to sort of maybe like rent out some
books that might be informative and sort
of read those through and then if it
sort of clicks with you and you find
that stuff interesting then I would
definitely recommend that I'd also just
sort of there's always going to be like
a leap of faith sort of elements to it
as well no-one's going to be 100% sure
until you're deeply in it I know some
boot camps offer like a one-day sort of
course or a one-week sort of course so
there are options to sort of dip your
feet in a little bit before you jump in
yeah cannonball and do it you never know
until you try you never know until you
thank you to you for popping in and
answering these questions for me if you
want more videos with either or both of
them in them let me know in the comments
down below in the meantime if you want
to see more of them I stream with Scott
on Twitch sometimes when we play games
together and we make fun of each other
and it's a fun time so the description
box down below but as well as their
instagrams if you want to follow them
they're kind of interesting I guess what
one question that I got which I've
gotten throughout the last couple of
months that I just want to clear up
someone asks am i still actively coding
in my job which yes I think my I left my
job video from a year ago was a little
bit misleading or maybe people didn't
watch the whole video but I just want to
clear it up I went to another software
engineering job and I'm still working
full time as a software engineer at a
company so yeah I'm still actively
coding that's still my thing and I
didn't leave software engineering yet
Never Say Never
so yeah I'm I'm still working I'm still
coding and stuff you know going to a job
40 hours a week Monday through Friday
that's me the most common question that
I got from this whole Q&A is around how
do I stay motivated as a software
engineer how do I grow as a software
engineer like when the code isn't good
enough or when I'm just talking about
excited about the technology what what
motivates you and how do you
stay motivated great question not
another one of those questions that I
asked myself all the day time for me I'm
the kind of software engineer that
really likes software engineering
because it's kind of a people problem
like technology I mean we think about it
in terms of computers and phones but
technology also means wheels and
plumbing and modern-day refrigeration
like all that kind of stuff to you but
they're all there to help make life more
convenient and accessible and easy to
live for people and reduce death and
whatever I really like software
engineering in that way of life it helps
people to do things that they couldn't
do before in advance the society and so
when I kind of get lost in the details
and lose my sense of motivation I kind
of bring myself back up to the 30,000
foot space and be like hey like why am I
doing this to begin with like why why
I'd even choose this field why why did
it why did I keep going in this field
and I remember it's because like I want
to work with people I like collaborating
with people I like solving problems for
people I like asking questions and
finding out things learning which are
all aspects to software engineering and
other careers too so that's what I do
for myself I think I mean one of the
reasons why I started this channel to be
completely honest is because there were
like other people that I know in tech
will never we talked about techie was
always like I'm sure I'd react it's like
the coolest thing and like that's the
thing that you should be focusing on
right now which didn't really resonate
with me cuz I was like cool but like why
like I don't know I mean I'm sure it's
cool and it's cool it's a really great
technology Thank You Facebook but it was
never like the technology that I was
like super jazzed about it was about
what technology enables I guess and I
think an important part of all of this
is taking a step back realizing and
accepting the fact that you're
demotivated and then figuring out where
to go from there if that means you have
to take a week
just kind of chill and take it easy fine
that's totally good like introspect ask
yourself hard questions talk to people
that you love and that you trust and try
to process it because I don't know
sometimes the answers come out of that
that you wouldn't expect and I think
it's important to address those when you
feel like you can so if you're in a
place to do that like I think it's a
always a really important thing to talk
about my motivations today have changed
a lot from my motivations like a month
ago even definitely like years ago and I
think addressing like what you want and
like what's important to you in life how
you want to live your life and thinking
about that in the context of like how
does this how does coding and software
engineering help that or enable that or
provide that I think are important
questions so that's it for today thank
you so much for watching especially if
you watch the very end and also thank
you to everyone who wrote in your
questions I'm sorry I didn't get to all
of them but I think that just tells me
that I should do more of these videos
because everyone has a lot of questions
and are thinking and feeling lots of
things and if my voice my videos help
then gosh darn it I think I'm doing a
good job all right as always don't
forget to subscribe hit the notification
belt smash the like button follow me on
instagram twitter cuz i'm way more
active on those because because it's
easier honestly and i'll see you next
time bye remember to Like and subscribe
like and subscribe smash that like
button punch that Bell button smash it
so jumping out I wouldn't go that far
okay three two one bye